it was icon week on Dancing with the  Stars and for seventeen-year-old bindi  Irwin that meant paying tribute to Grace  Kelly  Grace Kelly is my icon she is such a  strong fierce beautiful individual she  was a woman who stayed true to her  beliefs no matter what happened in life  and I can really relate to that but  honoring a princess isn't as easy as it  looks especially when you're injured  from the nice pins toenails are falling  off and blisters on every foot and she  hasn't stopped dancing Wow I've never  met anybody who's worked as hard she's  relentless  reducing the wildlife conservationist  regal dance earned her a score of 28 out  of 30